[Music]
so it's one of my favorite if not my
favorite time of year right now on the
farm which is
September because we're
harvesting pretty much everything is is
full production right now we're
harvesting tomatoes cucumbers
the
whole arsenal of vegetables are being
harvested which of course I love and I
love eating it uh but we're also
planting for the winter and the well
actually fall planting is pretty much
done we're planting for the winter right
now in green houses and it's a time
where even though we're doing all that
harvesting the the actual like energy of
the farm is slowing down a lot it's
relax it's more relaxing than it is in
the
spring all the pressure is mostly
gone um all we got left is just to fill
in whatever space is left on the farm
with winter crops that will mature by
November 7th in my
climate and uh that's what I'm doing
right now is I'm planting
kale that will hopefully be mature by
November 7th and we'll Harvest it
December January
February somewhere in there
and
um what I'm talking about is winter
farming or winter harvesting whatever
you want to call it there's a lot of
different terms out there but I'm
obsessed with it
because I love what I do I love growing
vegetables I'm obsessed with it and I
love eating all of this stuff and I
don't want it to end in the winter time
so winter farming when I first heard
about it and I first heard about Elliot
Coleman and what he's doing CU he's a
guy who kind of brought this to America
at
least um I was just obsessed I watched
every video I could possibly find about
winter farming and um he's pretty big
deal because he took a lot of European
techniques and brought him to America
where it's a lot colder um you know he's
growing in Maine which is really similar
climate to here uh in Wyoming in I'm
sure they get down to5 -20 almost every
winter Fahrenheit by the way and we get
down to that cold last year we got down
to30 and he made it possible to do this
stuff in green houses like what I'm
doing right now
and it's kind of a revolutionary Concept
in my opinion
because it means there's a possibility
of having freshh local food all year
round even in ridiculously cold climates
like ours and in a really short growing
season like ours I'm pretty sure Elliot
Coleman is a zone five uh I'm pretty
sure they're where they're at is a zone
five or something close to that and
we're in a basically zone five zone four
whatever a lot of that is kind of just a
a guideline each climate has its own
little nuances
but I'm obsessed with this winter
farming stuff and um
because the vegetables taste better A
lot of what we grow in the summertime is
actually the same stuff we grow in the
winter because
Wyoming uh heat loving crops don't do as
well so stuff like kale carrots cilantro
parsley all that stuff we grow a lot
more of it in the summertime because
it's still really cold here in the
summertime and so it's it's fun for me
to do this because it's just like the
last little job of the season
other than harvesting and then once this
is done all we got to do is Harvest
whatever we want whenever we want
somewhere between November 7th and
February 4th which is What's called the
prapan period and that's the time where
daylight is less than 10 hours and
plants don't really grow at all um you
know you're got to have to Google winter
farming Elliot Coleman to learn a lot
more about that but because I can't
explain all that in this video but in my
climate that's that's the date of less
than 10 hours of daylight and uh if you
figure that out in your climate you
could do all this stuff too and there's
a whole winter planting calendar which
I'll put a link to that in the
description too just in case you happen
to have a greenhouse and you want to try
some of this because there's still time
in most climates to plant a whole bunch
of the stuff I'm going to talk about in
this video probably not kale I'm
actually kind of risking it right now by
doing this this late but I'm going to
try but uh there's whole bunch of stuff
you can
grow to be mature by November and then
eat it all winter and if you're in the
South it's just going to be a hell of a
lot easier for you than what I'm doing
here um I think if you're in like South
Carolina you could probably grow
broccoli through the winter and stuff
you know we have an extreme climate here
so we have to be pretty picky about what
we grow but there's still a good 10 10
crops I could eat fresh in
January and I'm just obsessed with that
I think it's such a game changer that I
I want to see more people doing it and
that's why I'm making this video I want
to talk about it and uh if you find any
of that interesting keep watching I'm
going to share a couple tips that you
could do if you have a greenhouse of
some kind or even if you don't and I'm
going to go over the crops that we're
planting right now to harvest in January
so stay tuned
and enjoy
so this is my personal favorite winter
crop it's called claytonia or miners
lettuce it's this really weird
looking salad green that actually grows
in the mountains right around here in
Wyoming in the Rocky Mountains Colorado
Montana I've had ranchers come to my
booth in the winter time and ab
absolutely recognize this plant cuz
they've seen it in the mountains when
they're taking horses and cattle up
there and it's delicious it's super
weird uh it looks like I'm sure I'll do
videos later on when this is mature
because this is already too late to seed
more of this so we got plants in Paper
Pot trays that we'll transplant into
ground later on
but it's one of my favorites because it
tastes delicious and it is unbelievably
tough this stuff went through -30 last
year without batting an eyelash nothing
happened to it it was fine um it's a
little tricky to grow uh it's hard to
get it to germinate real thick um so I
kind of germinate it like I germinate
carrots which means I pay attention to
it a lot the first week that it's seated
in the ground and then this year I'm
trying it in Paper Pot trays
so I have extra just in case the stuff
in the ground doesn't germinate well and
I could just plant these plants um but
it's so good it tastes like lettuce a
lot like lettuce and like um maybe like
a sunflower choot combined or something
um but it's so cold hearty that's why it
grows in the mountains around here it
gets really cold in the mountains and
it's just awesome um we're going to grow
three or four beds of it this year uh
just because it's so popular and it
works as like a lettuce in the winter
time cuz real lettuce is a lot harder to
do in the winter I'm going to try some
real lettuce but it's tougher I've had a
lot more problems with it but claytonia
is a awesome one you buy one seed packet
it'll last you a couple years because
the seeds are ridiculously small um and
they uh it is kind of expensive but it's
awesome um just because of it's as tough
as spinach if not more and gives you
tons of salad um we'll be doing lots of
videos about it later on this year
showing you the harvesting process and
everything but miner's lettuce is a
you've got to grow it if you have a
greenhouse of any kind just throw some
seeds in the ground if you're Le if
you're like a zone six or lower than me
you probably still plant it right now
for a couple more weeks but um this one
was seated uh like a week ago about 10
days ago so that's like September 1st
for me um it's September 12th now so
probably a little too late for most
people
but still worth looking into you could
probably plant it into October in some
CL in most climates south of here but
awesome one to
do so this is parsley uh I've already
talked about it a bunch in my other
videos but we grow a lot of parsley here
and the reason is is it's ridiculously
cold hearty grows really well in cold
temperatures which we have a lot of here
so I've had parsley in my greenh
houses for the past three years and it
almost always survives perfectly through
the winter
um and what I mean by survive is it's
like if it's -30 I'm going to want to
harvest all of this before that because
it will get pretty damaged in unheated
Greenhouse like this
but it'll still survive and it'll grow
back really thick in March and April so
you get tons of harvests up until that
really big cold snap and then it goes
dormant for a little while and then it
comes back like crazy once we get more
than 10 hours of daylight again in
February so parsley's a bombproof one
it's more bombproof than cilantro my
experience and it tastes really sweet
and delicious so I love it
I mean I've talked about it a lot
already on this channel I don't want to
go over it again and again and again but
there's a reason why we plant it all the
time because it takes a long time to
grow a lot of people don't have it in
their Gardens reliably and it just turns
into this big bush of delicious
Herby goodness so that's
parsley all right so here's a crop
you're going to hear me talk about a
million times on this channel I already
have talked about it a million times and
that is
spinach number one winter
crop plant it it goes through ne30 no
problem it tastes ridiculously
sweet once it gets
cold and we'll get two or three cuts out
of this one bed we have nine beds this
year in the far on the farm that we'll
be harvesting from uh so far six are
planted we started planting this a week
ago now about 10 days ago this spinach
is about 10 days old and it'll be huge
by November just big plants this will
just be a carpet of spinach and it's a
bombproof one you got to do it if you're
winter growing no matter where you are
just got to do it um and you know it's
relatively easy once you start getting
colder nighttime temperatures it
germinates no problem we don't have to
worry about it too much and uh
just amazing so uh this
one it's the number one you got to do in
the winter time um can't lose with
spinach so definitely try spinach so on
either side of me are
carrots they were planted around August
1st in my climate that's the day that I
got to get all my winter carrots planted
or else it's pretty much not going to be
enough time in the growing season to get
them big enough by November but these
are going to be perfect this is the best
batch I've had so far in my farming
career we've got
six beds of winter carrots in these two
caterpillar tunnels and um this is like
for my booth in the winter time this is
what brings people back every week is
winter carrots call them candy carrots
they taste like they're sugar injected
into them because they are unbelievably
sweet um and I think part of that is the
variety we're growing but they just get
sweeter and sweeter as the winter
comes and uh once you get good at
growing carrots which I'm going to talk
about a lot on this channel because I
think
it's easiest way to fill your fridge
root seller whatever you got to store
food um by growing a garden but um once
you can grow carrots well you could do
this no problem because it's the same
technique is growing them in the summer
it's just getting the timing right and
growing them under a little bit of pro
protection so carrots are a must got to
do carrots so the last one I'm GNA talk
about is kale which is what I was
planting at the beginning of this video
and it's getting watered in right now
and I'm getting watered in too uh so I'm
going to make this quick but kale is a
real good one too it's bombproof
um not quite as bombproof as like
spinach and clonia I found that it gets
pretty wacky like past -2 it's pretty
rough and when it girl back it usually
goes to seed in March and April but I
always try it cuz sometimes you have a
mild winter and you might get a really
nice Harvest through January or whatever
and this is literally just the same kale
I grow outside it's called winter boore
I've tried the special winter kale
before and I don't really think it
tastes that good um
personally and it just gets kind of
weird but I'll probably try it again
eventually because I think part of that
just my soil is still getting good but
kale um we planted this like Late July
we seeded it J Late July and these
plants are not super healthy that's cuz
my Nursery is not so good yet but um I'm
pretty sure this will work uh something
we'll we'll Harvest something by
November um but uh yeah you got to try
kale too that's a really easy one if you
get it growing big enough you could no
matter what you could Harvest it into
December in a greenhouse no problem so
gotta try kale so if you want to do this
and you want to eat fresh vegetables in
January it really helps to have a
greenhouse of some kind
and there's ways to do it with a cold
frame uh depending on your climate it
works for sure but um a greenhouse in my
opinion is the easiest because um you
can just fit a lot more in the green
housee you know a Cold Frame you're
going to have you know a 4x4 little
section and you're going to eat that all
up by in like a week you know the one
thing about winter growing or harvesting
is you need a lot of space because
nothing is growing so if you want to
actually eat spinach all winter you need
a lot of it in a protected environment
so a little Greenhouse like what I have
behind me um these are called
caterpillar tunnels by farmer friend
I'll leave a link to them in the
description um these are so
cheap uh compared to to a high tunnel
which is what I grow a lot of my stuff
in these are so cheap and easy to put up
any Homesteader could do it um and it's
just a couple thousand dollars or
something as opposed
to a lot more money and a lot more time
to build a high tunnel um a real high
tunnel you know takes a 100 hours or
something to build and that depends on
which size you want it doesn't
necessarily take a 100 hours but in my
opinion it's a lot more effort and a lot
more stressful to build than one of
these things
um you know these things I have them in
the 100t by 16t lengths there's two of
them on the farm but I'm a farm so I
need it as big as possible but you could
get them as small as 25 foot and 14 foot
wide you can put that up in a weekend
and um they ship it to you in a kit you
don't have to really do any thinking
they do all of the they have the um how
to
assemble uh packet in the packaging and
it's really easy to put together it is
these took me about 10 hours to put
together and that's the same amount of
greenhouse space that I have in high
tunnels which took me literally 250
hours to build two high tunnels so just
that's the tradeoff you're getting with
these um they're not as windproof for
sure uh I'm going to have to beef mine
up a little bit to survive our wind here
in Wyoming but um if I was Homestead
which I'm not because I have a farm um I
would build these things and you could
do all your summer growing in here you
could grow your summer cucumbers and
tomatoes and stuff in here really easily
and then you could grow winter stuff um
and have a whole bunch just for your
family and uh there's all sorts of fun
little additions you can make to them on
their website I just went with the bear
bones because this is sort of like
a uh low-end Greenhouse for me on my
Farm I'm going to be building a lot more
fancy ones coming up here but um I I
love these things for how cheap they are
and um you could do everything I'm
talking about in this video in one of
these I've already done it through one
winter and it worked fine I would just
say definitely Orient them east to west
because the sunlight and you make sure
you get sun in the winter wherever you
put them because I oriented these uh
north south and they don't get as warm
nearly as warm um there's probably a 101
15 degree difference in warmth when the
sun does come out in the winter that
matters a lot for how well the
vegetables grow um and I found that
everything in here grows a lot slower
because I oriented that way and I think
that's why um so you want to orient him
East West so you get a lot more sun in
the winter time but other than that you
could do everything I said in this video
you just need some Frost covers to
protect protect them when it gets -20 or
whatever but um I've gone over that a
little bit in the videos but the whole
concept with Elliot Coleman style of
winter growing is you get the crops
mature by the last 10hour day and then
you cover them with one layer of white
row cover which you could get in a lot
of different places you get the lightest
layer of row cover um and that usually
will do the trick for most of these
crops you know if you get down to
negative really seriously below zero
you're probably going to want a couple
layers of that row cover just because
the more protection you have the more
the crops are going to do well and then
in my climate usually there's only a
couple weeks of that cold and then you
can take the extra layers off and you're
pretty good um you know it's not there's
going to be a learning curve with this
that's why I'm making this video is I
want to see more people doing it um and
I don't think there is that many people
doing it um
but there is a way to do it and uh the
more you experience growing like this um
the more I think you'll enjoy it and
you'll learn how to do it better I'm
still learning a lot um so but these
caterpillar tunnels are very cheap easy
to put together I highly recommend you
do that um if you already have a
greenhouse it should be pretty easy for
you to do all the things I'm talking
about you just got to buy the right
seeds and stuff and I didn't even talk
about nearly all the winter crops in
this video um because we're still still
going to be planting a few more like um
Tokyo bana which is a really fast
growing brass that's a good one I only
talked about the really easy ones in
this video that are tough um good
beginner crops and uh but all you need
is a greenhouse a little bit of
protection inside and you can do this
stuff so give it a shot if you have a
greenhouse if not buy one of
these so if you want to set up a garden
in your backyard that can grow all the
crops I talked about in this video
without having to weed or really put a
whole lot of effort in every week I
highly recommend you check out my
gardening course at the link in the
description I go over everything you
need to know from setting up your garden
in a no dig style where you don't have
to do weeding like I do on the farm and
plant spacing crop planting
watering everything you need to know
from seed to Heart on pretty much all
the crops I grow here on the
farm which is sort of the foundational
skills you need to do all the winter
stuff that I talked about in this
video highly recommend you check it out
it's gardening 101 at the link in the
description and start thinking about
growing a garden right now because it
takes a little bit of planning to do
really well next year because I know
we're at the end of our growing season
but if you had a hard growing season and
you tried
gardening and it didn't work out for you
you got a bunch of weeds this method of
growing is for you because all it takes
is uh few short days of hard work to set
up and then you just pretty much plant
and seed on schedule and then forget
about it and come Harvest when you need
to eat that's pretty much as simple as
it is once you get it all set up so
highly recommend you check that out if
you enjoyed this video please subscribe
like
and share with anybody who you think
might find it interesting and I will see
you in the next